I don't know much about cars or how they
work but I know they got wheels and
that's all you need to go fast in a
nutshell this is what's happening today
what they've done here is they've rigged
the entire car to be a video game
controller steering wheel the gas pedal
it's going to be a real functioning car
all used to control a virtual reality
video game be driving in real life doing
everything 100% for real
the only thing that won't be real is the
course and we will be driving on my diva
has so many friends the professional
partier sometimes you have a couple
friends over usually he invites hundreds
and it even got to the point where I
think Jenna got evicted or kicked out of
one of his last houses because the party
started getting too big the cops would
call him any time the residence holding
parties at his house he utilizes
warehouses has moved on to like actually
hosting personal parties at venues there
was like I think at least 200 people is
birthday party last night so now it's
the morning after it I feel like a
million bucks now we have to race car
it's a dressing a little race cars
around we do a lot of yourself I know a
lot about it get this scale like how the
heck are you getting 3d spatial tracking
data for this vehicle and all this stuff
I figured out how they're doing it first
thing they're using to attract the cars
position is not too much of a surprise
there's a GPS system that's the
foundation so basically it starts with a
GPS but it's a lot more accurate than
your phone but that's not how we're
actually getting accurate like true
movement of the vehicle that's not being
recorded through that they have tapped
into the car's ABS system the traction
control system for the car and the
internal computer in the vehicle is
going to send that car's positional data
out it is it's accurate enough now
exactly how far is moving in any
direction that is where the actual fine
detail car position data is coming from
it's crazy to say thing to think about
that a computer inside the vehicle it's
able to tell where it is in 3d space
simply by judging the speed of the
wheels there's also going to be an
augmented reality headset they're using
which is cool two little screens with
mirrors that you can see all that stuff
enough apparently this thing's got a
little juice to it let's get some lunch
we came here two hours early
me oh hey guys remember that thing we
worked on all its spring called lifeline
today is the day we lock the rest of the
edits blocking the Edit is when you sat
there you've chopped all your footage
and then you go through and make all the
adjustments you adjusted yourself you
show it to an audience they you
critiques make all your adjustments make
all your cuts you keep doing this over
and over and over until it's perfect
when you lock your at it ideally that
means it's perfect
they have to do sound and these thick
and visual effect QC legal clearance
that ATR know what now that know that
something matters because walking the
edit is like the biggest step you can
take with the project outside of
post-production
we've already locked the first five
episodes and I'm going off today to lock
the remaining three and then it's done
big moves big steps when people are
probably wondering when my fine comes
out we don't know for sure maybe like
October or something like that
I don't know YouTube might get mad at us
let me tell you anything else but
whatever screw it I think it's around
October with too tired of all its
secrecy I hope it's not a train wreck
when I go in to try to lock the other
little justice are happening all over
the place and you go and you pick some
things and something else works and
everyone tomorrow you go in to discover
that the stuff you spent like two days
fixing just like got ignored we'll see
if that happened you could
waiting around no shoot would be
complete without technical issues
million reasons why that's happening
it's cool actually they're running the
whole thing through unity pumping all
the data into unity and outputting it as
well so as someone who's dabbled in that
software it's really impressive see how
he'll flexible of a engine it is until
then catch up some on some emails a new
phone the Google pixel okay so here's
the funny story yesterday when we came
here for the rehearsal there's tons and
tons of tons and tons of flies we
supplier that today the reason for the
flies was because this hanger was
actually abandoned and a bunch of birds
were housed in it and like we're flying
it and living in here also birds were
dying in here when I first came in here
like who we feel that there's enough or
was littered with dead bird and there
were flies like mad so there's a
pressure wash and clean of all the
divers and it's a even tildes every day
that birds still sometimes randomly fall
out of the rafters
so this is Sam live great
it's going to be go straightening and
other drivers then we're going to bring
out our yeah what's up I'm Terry I'm one
of the cofounders of corridor digital
YouTube channel we've been making videos
funny thing is we actually we actually
did a video a while back on our Sam and
Nico Channel I've driven a car with
video screens attached to my eyes unable
to be the road Sam yesterday we were
discussing things about the track and of
course what was the thing you mentioned
you want to use so is there an emergency
break my plan so on my practice run I
was really aggressive because I just
wanted to drive a car and drive real
fast but as I kind of went through it I
started realizing like this is a game if
the game is a game you have to play by
its rule not yours I might not do the
most aggressive run for my actual times
here I'm going to try and do the
cleanest run not the fastest one because
the time they add time penalties and
they're pretty severe play nice and
smooth might actually have a chance shot
of it and so what you think it's serious
a video stream of what I'm doing but a
data stream of where my car's position
is and they're they have an exact
duplicate of the level with their red
right now out real I'm gonna breathe
Sandra never agree how'd you really well
so it's cool to see him be able to
utilize his Street areas here we go
that's why what a naming system as well
as this previous experience oh man I'm
off the track again saying oh he's in
the lobby now we'll just so many point
[Applause]
that was really cool you got a car in an
empty parking lot just turn rev it
oh it's fine it's fine it's like the car
is moving at the same speed your notion
no motion let's worry or we find out the
results stand up first mod got sexy dr.
Levi got third and DA mrs. Hobbs's ito
got toy so before building are the only
people in his mortality the numbers
winners of acceptance Pete really really
really competitive and it is actually
really intimidating okay so I was
incredibly hard because this whole
elaborate system they're putting
together it works pretty well but once
you start done in it it starts to fall
apart just a little bit but that's
obviously because this is like super DIY
you know it's super super super
impressive but I you know I think really
only real improvement right now I think
really offering is for viewers for other
people watching because right now when
I'm in the heads that I get to see it
all I feel at all it's super cool but
really what they need to be they need to
get that feed from the headset onto the
screen so you guys can see the drivers
POV there's a little bit of latency
going through the Wi-Fi and the data
that's being transferred here so I feel
like you know at the end of the day you
want any gaming channel you've seen the
player's perspective super cool
experience though being able to grab the
car be able to freewheel it out in the
middle but giant like a giant concrete
whatever that's a giant block is the
kind of stuff like when I'm bored or
whenever I find a giant be parking a lot
I go whip shading around in it you know
being able to do this as part of my day
job is an absolute blessing just wanted
to thank the Acura guys are hooking us
up and setting this all up hopefully
we get to do something like this again
in the future because it's super super
cool kind of simply live
[Music]
and with the t-34 doing that burning off
traction control in your car I'll help
ya divided toys of what I would do on my
Monday are definitely to racing a car a
real car in a virtual environment
[Music]